عندما انفجرت Chad GPT في
الوعي العام في أواخر العام الماضي ،
فاجأت قدراتها عناوين الصحف العالمية ، حيث
صرحت أنها تمكنت من اجتياز
امتحان المحامين وإجراء محادثات نصية شبيهة بالبشر ،
فهي تكتب
أوراق مصطلحات الكود الحاسوبي وحتى
الخماسي التفاعيل شكسبير ، فهو ليس ذلك فقط.
أحد البرامج التي تمتلكها Google Microsoft والعديد من
الشركات الأخرى لديها برامج ذكاء اصطناعي خاصة بها ، كان
الناس مفتونين
وخائفين من أن الخوف قد زاد
الشهر الماضي عندما وقع أكثر من 350
عالم كمبيوتر ومسؤول تنفيذي تقني
على جملة واحدة قالت إنها
تخفف من مخاطر الانقراض من
يجب أن يكون الذكاء الاصطناعي أولوية عالمية جنبًا إلى جنب مع
مخاطر المجتمع الأخرى مثل
الأوبئة والحرب النووية ،
أحد الموقعين عليه هو رجل أطلق عليه
اسم الأب الروحي
للذكاء الاصطناعي ، ترك جيفري هينتون
وظيفته في Google حتى يتمكن من
مناقشة مخاطره بحرية.  الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهذا ما أريد أن أسأله عنه
اليوم ، أرحب بكم جيفري ، شكرًا أولاً
قبل أن ندخل في
الأشياء السيئة التي أريد أن أعرفها ، أعطي
الناس إحساسًا
بالإبداع المذهل الذي أنتج أه Ai
والإثارة التي يجب عليك  لقد شعرت بذلك في
أي نقطة بدأت تدرك
كأستاذ أنك كنت قد بدأت تعلم
أنك تحصل على أجهزة كمبيوتر
لتكون قادرة على التفكير في
ذلك في عام 1986 بدأنا في استخدام
خوارزمية اخترعها العديد من
الأشخاص المختلفين الذين يطلق عليهم  الانتشار العكسي
وفي تلك المرحلة كان بإمكاننا جعل أجهزة الكمبيوتر
تفعل القليل من التفكير
لكنها لم تنجح كما كنا
نأمل وفي تلك المرحلة لم
نفهم حقًا أن كل ما نحتاجه هو المزيد من
البيانات وأجهزة الكمبيوتر الأكبر حجمًا
ولكن  بحلول عام 2006 ، حصلنا على ذلك ثم
بدأنا في رؤية تقدم حقيقي بدأنا في
رؤية شبكات عصبية اصطناعية تم
تشكيلها بعد أن يكون الدماغ قادرًا على القيام
بكل أنواع الأشياء التي
لم يكن الذكاء الاصطناعي الرمزي التقليدي قادرًا على فعلها مثل
التعرف على الأشياء والصور التي تتعرف على
الكلام وتكون  قادرًا على التنبؤ
بالكلمة التالية في جملة ما
بالنسبة لك كان هناك نوع من عبور
لحظة روبيكون عندما أدركت
أن أجهزة الكمبيوتر أصبحت
جيدة جدًا وقوية جدًا في الذكاء الاصطناعي ، لذا أعتقد في
عام 2012 أن اثنين من طلابي الخريجين
إلياسوتسكوفا الذي أصبح الآن  صنع كبير
العلماء في Open Ai و Alice
krishovsky
um شبكات عصبية كانت
أفضل بكثير من الأنظمة السابقة التي
تتعرف على الأشياء والصور ، لذا سيكون
لديك مليون صورة مع ألف
نوع مختلف من الأشياء ، ولم
يكن بمقدور الأشخاص سابقًا أن يفعلوا أفضل من الحصول على
25 خطأ وفجأة حصل إيلي وأليكس على
15 خطأ وكان ذلك
إنجازًا كبيرًا ، فمن الواضح أن هذه الأشياء
كانت تعمل الآن بشكل أفضل بكثير من
الطرق السابقة لممارسة
الذكاء الاصطناعي عندما بدأت في الانتقال من كونك
مبتهجًا بشأن كل هذا إلى القلق
حقًا فقط  قبل بضعة أشهر ، أعني أنني كنت
دائمًا قلقًا بشأن أشياء مثل
ما الذي سيحدث للأشخاص الذين
فقدوا وظائفهم لـ Ai وهل سيكون هناك
روبوتات قتالية وماذا عن كل
الأخبار المزيفة التي ستصدرها
وماذا عن الصدى  يتم
إنتاج Chambers عن طريق جعل الناس ينقرون على
الأشياء التي تجعلهم غاضبين
من كل تلك الكلمات التي كنت قلقًا
بشأنها ، لكن فكرة أن هذه الأشياء ستصبح
أكثر ذكاءً منا وقد تحل
محلنا في الواقع ، لقد شعرت بالقلق فقط
منذ بضعة أشهر عندما  قلبت
وجهة نظري فجأة ، كانت وجهة نظري أنني
أعمل على محاولة صنع ذكاء رقمي
من خلال محاولة جعله مثل الدماغ
وأفترض أن الدماغ أفضل
ونحاول فقط اللحاق بالدماغ.
أدركت فجأة أن
الخوارزمية التي لدينا هي في الواقع أفضل
من الدماغ بالفعل وعندما نوسعها
سنجعل الأشياء أكثر ذكاءً منا
والسبب الأساسي لذلك
أعتقد أنك قلته هو أن
أجهزة الكمبيوتر تتعلم
على الفور و  كل كمبيوتر في
العالم إذا كان متصلاً يتعلم يتعلم
أنك تعرف كل شيء
بشكل صحيح ، لذا اشرح مقياس
قوة الحوسبة مقارنةً بالدماغ ، حسنًا ،
إذا تعلمت شيئًا ما والآن
تريد أن تنقل إلي
ما تفعله هو أنك تنتج  الجمل
وأحاول اكتشاف كيفية
تغيير نقاط قوة الاتصال في
عقلي حتى أتمكن من إنتاج نفس
الجمل ولكن ليس هناك الكثير من
المعلومات في الجملة ، لذا فهي
عملية بطيئة للغاية ومؤلمة تنقل ما
تعرفه إلى شخص آخر
ولكن  إذا كان لديك
جهازي كمبيوتر رقمي مختلفين لهما نفس
الطراز تمامًا من العالم ويرى
أحدهما مستندًا والآخر يرى
مستندًا مختلفًا ويتعلم كل منهما من
المستند الذي يشاهده وهكذا إذا كان
لديك 10000 جهاز كمبيوتر من هذا القبيل  يبدو الأمر
كما لو كان لديك 10000 شخص
يتعلمون جميعًا من بيانات مختلفة وبمجرد
أن يتعلم شخص ما شيئًا
يعرفه الجميع ويتمتع الجميع بقدر
الذكاء الذي يتم تقويته من خلال هذا
المتوسط ​​بحلول ذلك الوقت ، نعم ،
هذا شيء يعني
نظريًا حتى البشر يمكنهم
لن نصل أبدًا إلى هذا المكان ، لا يمكننا أبدًا
رؤية بيانات كافية ، الأمر سيستغرق منا. لا
أعرف كم من الوقت ، لكن آلاف
وآلاف السنين لرؤية أكبر قدر من البيانات
كما رأينا GPT 4 ،
لم نتمكن من القيام بذلك في العمر
وهكذا  من الممتع مرة أخرى
التفكير في
القوة الاستثنائية التي يتمتع بها هذا الكمبيوتر
ولكن القلق من
أنه أمر مقلق لأننا
لا نعرف أي أمثلة
لأشياء أكثر ذكاءً يتم التحكم فيها بواسطة
أشياء أقل ذكاءً
أعني مع المجتمعات البشرية التي
تمتلكها غالبًا  ديكتاتوريون ليسوا أذكياء
مثل البعض مثل الفلاحين ولكن هذا ليس
فارقًا كبيرًا أنهم في نفس
الدوري ولكن هنا ستصبح هذه الأشياء
أكثر ذكاءً منا
والقلق هو أننا يمكن أن نبقيهم
يعملون من أجلنا عندما "  أكثر
ذكاءً منا كثيرًا ، فعلى سبيل
المثال ، تعلموا كيفية خداعهم ،
سيكونون قادرين على خداعنا إذا أرادوا ذلك